el anuncio de la extensión de la
cuarentena no cayó bien en el sector del
comercio ni tampoco en el sector del
turismo que esperaban empezar a
reactivarse desde el 14 de septiembre
cabe recordar que esta cuarentena
estricta de nivel 4 y el toque de queda
nocturno iniciaron el 2 de agosto y se
tenía previsto que fueran hasta el 13 de
septiembre sin embargo el gobierno del
estado de victoria cuya capital es
melbourne ha dicho que a pesar de que
las cifras de contagio han disminuido
pues esto no ha sido suficiente para
aflojar desde ahora estas medidas y esto
es de cara a diciembre porque se acaba
de acordar junto con el gobierno federal
y los demás estados que se va a buscar
de las fronteras interestatales se abran
para las fiestas de navidad para finales
de diciembre sólo uno de los ocho
estados decidió no ser parte de este
acuerdo que es el estado de western
australia mejoran entonces las cifras en
melbourne pero el gobierno se rehúsa a
retirar medidas iremos entonces con
cuarentena de nivel 4 y toque de queda
hasta el 28 de septiembre y desde allí
iniciará un plan de reactivación
económica bastante
que busca que en melbourne y el resto
del estado de victoria estén listos para
las fiestas de navidad y asia australia
pueda conectar a las familias en medio
de los estados para fin de año